start that hello welcome to the Buffy
days once we can hang every tuesday at
two p.m. pacific right here Oh Gates
woke up how you doing hey do folks I'm a
host on you are joined by Michael mehar
d hey I'm Tyson ruse hello you handsome
gentleman's having representing bro yeah
team bro yeah so who better to talk
about buddy fantasy role-playing games
then then team bro 2015's been a great
year for video games yes we have a bunch
of stuff to talk about on today's show
that let alone metal gear solid 5 the
phantom pain which we've all been
playing and but one of the games were
playing earlier this year a lot of and I
want like a sitrep from both of you it
was the witcher 3 wild hunt which we've
today seen the first trailer for their
their new expansion pack yeah a little
teaser trailer yeah how far you in wall
done if you completed Waldo oh yeah I
finished it you finished it I sex with
everyone briefly yes even that one all
of them yeah Mike Robert you yeah done
with it way to go yeah but have not even
I've done it I'm like a hundred and
thirty hours into that game I played 100
20 yeah yeah but I'm like I'm like you
know apparently there's no spoilers that
tyranny there's a part where you think
it's going to end yes so I even haven't
completed that yet 130 hours yes so
really good that's that part where I'm
like oh the gay must be ending right
here it's over and then all of a sudden
you're like oh wait now and then more
there's like 20 more hours in can play
at that game what's I happen so you play
about 120 hours of 120 but I did a lot
of random [ __ ] yeah well having sex with
NPCs apparently yeah yeah I mean that
was part of my goal but Nate you kind of
screws you over at the in there because
then no one loves you at the end again
no spoiler by the way sorry yeah just
like life it is you go around have have
you seen I turns out have you seen that
ending no haven't no spoilers I won't
spoil what a sensation all i know is be
a good guy and pick one person i've
already [ __ ] that up i think mike what
about you how about how long have you
played well uh yeah something like you
know 110 120 range i meet i beat it I
kind of played through it like just two
weeks trains for you were doing between
like right before I moved out to the
west coast and I was kind of you know
trying to do all this icon and I try to
do all the witcher contracts yeah those
bees which were over might some of my
favorite parts
yeah once i finish the main story you
know there's that like that one climax
and you think that's the end but in jail
just keeps on truckin so many climax so
I've kind of that yes ty had many climax
as well it sounds like Annie so it
sounds like a game that it was a game
when I was playing it that I realized I
had the same problem I would open more
games at the same thing with fallout new
vegas which I only completed I've after
hundreds of hours I only competed like
three months ago because I just I never
liked completing games because I'm
worried that I won't like I'm gonna miss
out on certain quests and stuff like
that so I like paced myself on the
witcher 3 and now I've met with your
solids out like five percent of that
game complete after like 20 hours or
something incall in November and we've
just found out about hearts of stone
which is the new furniture like first
paid expansion first real expansion yeah
for the rich earthy world home which is
gonna have another 10-plus hours at
worth of gaming content is good you
forgave me it's a good year it's at
October so we've a little bit of time
for Metal Gear Solid do you think you're
gonna have any times actually get into
the expansion yeah it depends how much I
invest into metal gear right now I I
mean you know me I actually don't like
Metal Gear games yeah I love phantom
pain like I actually love this one it
reminds me a lot of it kind of combines
a lot of those like role-playing
elements of like destiny and then with
like the open world of Witcher but it's
all modern or more modern it's like you
know set in the 80s but whatever like
it's awesome the gameplay is amazing so
I don't see myself quitting that anytime
soon I'm like you by the way I'm like I
mean I'm three percent complete I play
the game for like 10 hours so yeah and
it's hard to like parallel play these
types of games yeah it's like jump from
one open world game in other I was well
yeah and I mean and and if you kind of
like factor in that like you know you
have to how much free time you have you
know like are you married you have kids
you like I mean like all that stuff
right like and I don't know yeah but I
mean you know there you go you'll have
more time than most people then are some
people yeah but like how do you factor
in like how do you now make time for
Fallout and then metal gear and then
some kind of expansion that comes out
you know in October right yeah octobre
13 so I'm gonna try and sell you on it
justice it's 10 hours though right
that's it that's what they said 10 hours
at least you know yeah a gameplay
cannery what I was flipping round up on
that day right or they estimate up like
they say over a hundred hours again I
thought that when they said about the
witcher through Walt on phone
they said 200 hours and that's like
that's you could there's probably over
200 hours now but you really have to dig
deep yeah the good cop nurses have sex
with really every every bigs yet even
have to go that really won that one
naughty place where like they all the
girls were masked yeah yeah oh yeah no
standards no standard it's like the poor
man's whorehouse it's actually a rich
man's with not any cheap so yeah i
speaking to host on is michael Hart yeah
what do you think of how you know how to
take that do you think you have a finds
a play the witcher 3 while helmet comes
out oh sorry i meant i would like to but
realistically i probably won't get to it
until early next year just because like
you said fallout 4 and metal gear solid
5 these are games to inherently require
a huge time commitment and you know
there's they're very different things
fall out for being more of a sandbox and
then your salad being this emergent
gameplay in base kind of open world but
then there's halo comes out like oh yeah
tomb raider right after yeah tomb raider
same days fallout halos two weeks before
that I'm there's a lot and then like you
know early December there's just cause
then I'll be playing rainbow 6 siege and
stuff I don't think anyone's go like not
enough of us have gotten around to
playing much Mad Max either no because
just phantom pain stay think about game
of the year now like think of many games
you have to play now yeah like it even
have some sort of valid opinion on what
game of the year is it's all I have to
do vol your time now to like Metal Gear
to fall out the to Mater to halo 2 Just
Cause 3 not even destiny we think too
like all the sounds coming out soon for
that as well versus you started today
yeah alright well let me try to sell you
on us just in case 10 hours of gameplay
a crew of the such as including such
stuff as a crew of breaking artists
spending a nice partying with ghosts
test its smarting the most bizarre
creature girls has ever faced and
there's also rune worlds which are new
mechanism and combat I believe they got
into detail of what that exactly is
which they were almost out of room words
ya know ya words I room where it's no I
feel like it's some sort of like like
specking in one type of fun or another
or perhaps against like specific enemies
okay no they haven't they i'm going to
do talia and their design for level 30
plus characters so kind of endgame ii
folks mostly taking place right no man's
land on oxen first there's a new lady in
it as well who apparently Shanna is from
the first game yep who may
able to you know you can also they said
unique romance in there that's me what I
picked out of it how unique romance do
you want unique or mine so like okay I'm
raag sure I'm open frog pig it's 2015
Danny what was that big thing that came
with the cows big cow Beast oh the i
forgot what his name wasn't are no it
was not a Minotaur it was a good guess
though Mike McConnell what was it was
like some b state because people were
killing cows and selling their high just
like some light exploit in the game yeah
and then like the bovine justice warrior
came out and started screwing you up
code was cold I don't know I mean so
that's what I'm calling you now yeah my
god there's blood maybe not executive
for that yeah and also okay my favorite
thing about this actually which may make
me double down for the hard copy of this
is that there's a limited edition hard
copy of this expansion coming out that
get the includes two pairs of deck card
a Gwent cards yeah two decks of Gwent
which is important to think why are they
giving you two I was like oh yeah chase
if you haven't you could play with
somebody because you're the one person
and it comes out rules on how to play it
like that's the most important part I
also like the idea I maybe I prefer the
idea that they only give you one Gwen's
deck and then you'd have to like search
the real world to find somebody to play
grant for it I trying to expand on your
social skills exactly how dedicated you
are you to Quint yeah you must find when
players that's another quest we can
delete tender now though yes are you
finally finally I so it's interesting
because this is one of two expansions
that we know about it's coming out for
Wild Hunt and this one's kind of on the
smaller scale like 10 hours it's it's
nothing to you know sort of is it's it's
a decent matter gameplay but they're
bringing another one we're just going to
have a whole new world so fascinating a
hue one 2016 okay I think that's why and
$25 get you both right yes and they
haven't even announced what individual
prices would be I know I don't think
there is much i just got it see that's
the thing like the new world aspect of
it is kind of leading me to just almost
plan on playing this next expansion
early next year joggers yep being such a
big game and like you want to just kind
of absorb yourself in that game if you
like that be the perfect lead-in to the
next huge one i'm curious you guys when
there is like a lull like a doldrum
period where there's not a lot of games
coming out is there any game you guys go
back to like constantly not so this year
between
I sort of i think witcher was launched
at a perfect time this year begins going
into that sort of summer lull yeah a lot
of people had a bunch of time I think
phantom pain if it was released any
later this year would be in a little bit
not trouble but it would be difficult to
squeeze in but the game that I went back
and played and this summer was actually
43 and New girgis yeah because I was
looking forward to fallout 4 and I know
there was like aspects of those open
world games that I hadn't really and
it's indicating new vegas haven't played
yet kiss vol III i wanted to try playing
in a different type of way and those
games are kind of good for a petition
highway and yeah anything you've gone
back to it's been pretty stacked
actually since Q it stitched I think it
will be the witcher at this point i
think that all all power through metal
gear you know play that for a long time
because i'm really enjoying it and then
i'll definitely try out fallout tomb
raider and just cause 3 but yeah I mean
there's there's always like I go I go
back to civ 5 all the time there's
nothing going on you know and it's a
game I was playing after the witcher and
in between metal gear you know and so I
could see myself going back like Mike
said going back to like you know next
year Lee next year when maybe not of
tons coming up maybe right before well I
guess that depends a woman chart and
chart was what februari now God yet so I
mean one next year yeah so I I probably
would go back to at least this first
expansion early next year you know maybe
right after the holidays like when CES
is going on there's nothing coming down
that John real oh I think I'm the same
thing as well yeah oddly enough for all
contemplate jungle perfectly because
let's be honest actually the game that
were probably all playing in our spare
time I know anytime I've got five
minutes to an hour me and my girl boot
up rocket League Cups as possible so
yeah perfect just short bursts game yeah
yeah long yeah you win against weekend
you can just play for like two hours
yeah good and then I mean and I mean
with metal gear I can't it so that you
you have to dedicate time to that yeah
like you can get lost in that game for
multiple hours so I mean yeah I don't I
I think it's great that CD Projekt is
doing this I think that they have there
obviously you know with in good favor of
the audience you know like they've done
a great job with their DLC the last you
know you know couple months all the
freestyle free stuff and then for 25
bucks you get two expansions now which
is a great deal and that second one
supposed to be really meaty so I mean I
I mean I saw what six million copies of
the game
just announced that so I definitely see
a lot people picking that stuff up it
just might not be until early January
yeah probably limited edition coming as
well I both yeah for all you folks who
were looking to check out which of three
octobre 13 desmond hearts of stone is
coming out so let us know in the
comments whether you are going to pick
that up yourselves I let us know if
you're still playing the witcher 3 or if
like these guys you've actually managed
to complete it and are just chomping it
on site Christ let us know in the chat
or in the comments below we have stacked
show today folks bunch of stuff going on
we're going to talk a lot about destiny
to point over a while Mike will get you
back on for that our favorite moments of
metal gear solid 5 the phantom pain as
well but in just a sec I'm going to talk
a little chat about Mario maker and
state of the wii u right after oh my god
it's a trailer for hearts of stone
greetings get it do you want my help
it's a deal hey folks there's something
you might not know about me I'm a wii u
owner I own a wii-u do you own a wii-u
peter brian by proxy my roommate has one
your ears here's the one we you have
sold yeah fair enough i'm at uh Spinelli
do you own a Wii U yes I do yeah did you
consider yourself in the Tendo fan kind
of yeah a little bit what was it that
got you to buy with you uh actually the
main reason why bottle wii u was for
bayonetta 2 oh yeah good shot at ten at
a ten on gamespot com but you know
before we started handing the matter
like I can't Cassidy regime Danny get
used to it yeah Thank You Bernard and
peter brian kevin i miss you yeah what
was it that made you get away you you're
volatile matter with you i moved into an
apartment but I moved into that
apartment because of how do we okay yeah
is this josh is we you yes it is Josh
why did you buy or were you when
winwaker alright good chef ah but if i
didn't have one to use i would buy one
mmm and why would you buy one get one um
well partially cuz it's my job but I
think Nintendo has a ton of excellent
exclusives and that obviously you can't
get anywhere else because they're
Nintendo and their exclusive and there's
such interesting games and Mario maker
is one of them the most recent one I
think is a probably underestimated by
the audience at large he's probably
looking in like okay it's mario game
where you can drag and drop items big
deal but huge implications in terms of
like you know the amount of gameplay you
can get out of a single game and how
creative you know different people can
get and you can sample that creativity
you know from people around the world
and to me that is a very enticing thing
but i could see how people who aren't
really into nintendo exclusives might
avoid the wii u because frankly it just
doesn't get as many you know triple a
big games that you can guarantee will be
on x1 xbox one in PS yeah and i'm
interested madden well it's kind of a
funny story angle you have because the
reason you bought it was actually
because of a third party game which
nintendo
didn't develop on the wrong right what
other games do you own you were you like
what do you like doing on your wii u's
when you go back to every couple of
months or do you play every now and
again well other than bein today
actually i think i own wonderful 101 as
well okay like I do i do by like up like
nintendo games from time to time one of
the major series i'm more like a fan of
his legend of zelda corners but it the
system isn't really one I like always
constantly come back to you it's just
it's only one ever like you know they'll
release some kind of charming cute
adorable sort of like you touch like
exclusive title that I'll be like okay
it's time to go play the wii u again
it's like a tentpole game sort of system
it's like I sometimes I kind of forget I
have one for a little while and then
something comes out like my American
it's like oh great I get to play this
for a couple of weeks or like mario kart
was another good game which everyone was
playing forever like New Super Mario
Brothers was kind of a little bit okay
it's like turning in their tuning into
like a TV channel you'd never watch
because they're playing the thing or
something yeah oh I love that movie I'm
gonna tune in just for this and then
quietly never return so it's sold 10
million units it came as November 2012
actually now so like almost almost three
years ago yeah and the ps4 comparatively
is sold 25 million units the xbox one we
don't know exactly what we're being
around the 15 million mark and people
are thinking and what do you think it
was was that sort of the reason why the
wii u didn't catch on Peter what what is
it that sort of considering the massive
success of the we didn't carry over for
the wii u there are three reasons I
think one is what I mentioned earlier is
that people know that they're not going
to be getting the exclusive or the games
from you know they can be soft EA like
all those big publishers on the wii u
because recent came out sooner but
people understood that those consoles
were coming yeah and and i think when
they when they coupled that with the
other fact i just mentioned they
probably decided to wait for the more
powerful system but lastly i think the
gamepad is sort of an underwhelming
offering considering you know they're
following the wii with the wiimote which
was such a revolutionary thing do even
though it didn't make sense at first it
caught on and i think people were
expecting something that would match
that or Trump that and what they got was
a very uncomfortable controller that is
a slow tablet yeah so yeah i just i
think the entire thing
is underpowered and was perhaps rush to
market it's tough to say but that to me
is why the wii u just isn't doing so hot
it's interesting about the tabla because
I friends over on the weekend who don't
bidding there and she points adopting
she's what the hell is that oh it's the
Wii U and she said oh it's like an ipad
for your wii and i was like no no no
yeah it's a different thing and she's
like oh so it's like they made a
portable version like no no no there's
an actual console here this is the
controller and like just the fact that
it took three questions to try and
communicate like what that is matt is
there any game like do you have any
future for your wii u is there any game
you're looking forward to that's coming
out over the next while like does mario
maker interest you oh yeah yeah i mean
i'm definitely interested in picking up
super mario maker but other than that
just the next election is l again to be
honest which do you think it'll come out
on the wii u yeah i mean the other day
that's true we behave just a twilight
princess scenario where it does come out
on the wii u and on the NX but we still
have no idea what he'll the NX is so it
may just be a wii u title yeah did you
have any sort of idea or any sort of
insight or maybe just a gut feeling on
when we'll see the MX you think of
something y su cara mia moda told me
yesterday haha christmas 2016 is it
something you think i'll see you d three
next year like they've been talking
about it yeah couple years yeah a year
in a change where you're going to see it
at a Nintendo Direct during a slow point
in the year or we're going to see it at
e3 I don't think it makes sense for them
to do anything at TGS because Nintendo
basically ignores TGS yeah strange yeah
but it's you know big Chronicles X is
coming on December great and that looks
awesome in another like 100 our game but
yeah I'm super served for that I'm
looking that's probably apart from Zelda
that the only way you game laughter that
I am interested in yeah I've still got a
bunch more to meps a lot like dovin into
for whatever reason it always seems to
be like the B console to whatever is
happening on my pc or ps4 xbox one right
like Donkey Kong tropical freeze a slob
really delving into like I got it and
then just played a little bit but it's
weird it's like a bee console for so
many people but so many of the games
that are exclusive to it or like they
pack in so much charm and inventive
little gameplay mechanics that you just
you kind of don't find out
where it's it's still amazing to me that
a company that is able to do that as
well as Nintendo get good shot there
yeah you know can't find a market for
for these games and it's just the
changing face of gaming becoming more
mainstream I think where people want the
Hollywood experience and a Nintendo just
hasn't really captured that as well as
other publishers yeah when they think
about some of the directions which sort
of lied to know like the the other
consoles are going with like a bigger
support on indie games like sort of
bolstering their lineups and like the
massive growth we're seeing in pc with
like smaller type games and like games
that people play for years and years
like it's almost like the wii is tapping
into like it's almost like there's a
communication problem where people of
our generation get why the wii u work so
the wii works but for the younger crowd
that's just this weird relic of a sort
of an older type of video game i will
tell you this though my nephew who is
i'd say seven years old all he wants for
christmas is a wii u not really that is
the only thing he wants an attitude yeah
he wants it primarily for Skylanders
Disney infinity but also splatoon Wow
what tune is something that is really
resonated with him and I talked to him
once in a while and a lot of his friends
play that game I think Nintendo has
actually done a great job of capturing
maybe a modest-sized audience of a
younger generation with splatoon that I
think we don't see that's bizarre it's
sort of the reverse situation and when I
was up packs as well last week or the
weekend before last the amount of
students playing that was going I was
actually a little alarming I was like oh
wow a lot of people playing now have you
played that at all mad a little bit of
my friends house yeah are they so it's
really good actually it's just like that
it seems to have like a set of like a
decent amount of games that's getting
bigger bigger bigger but I just feel
like closer we get to the NX the least
chance this console has like are we sort
of like we're done with growth on wii u
like you think people gonna pick it up
over the next year so before we hear
more by dmx people will pick it up but
that's not going to be enough to really
create like a trend like an upward trend
in sales right i mean i think you know
nintendo is still making money off the
we you with game sales i think that's
that's evident their hardware at this
point is so outdated that i'm sure it's
really cheap to produce and the course
are making a lot of money
the 3ds in those games so I mean it's
not killing Nintendo but I think they're
giving it as much support as they need
to up until the NX is available but I am
concerned about the NX and I just it's
hard to see how Nintendo is going to
turn things around when it comes to the
perception of such a large audience like
millions of people day one not over the
course of four years yeah with a trickle
of games they have to do it day one and
if they don't do it this time but the NX
is probably to be their last console do
you think I'm post it Watson Nintendo
will struggle even more but I did you
bring that up I'd like you think about
like he was such a massive core no wind
sock or guiding elements to their to
their company that like yeah like you
have to imagine like he was really like
you know deep into the NX um you know I
don't imagine that he is the linchpin I
know I obviously his absence is going to
leave you know a void in Nintendo and
how they do things but but there's I
think they have the ability to to do
something intelligent if they take their
time and do things right i mean we saw
sony do it with the PlayStation 4 then
we have mark Cerny to develop that
hardware because the ps3 was a
complicated expensive system to develop
for so if Sony can turn it around
hardware wise by taking a different
route I think Nintendo can as well but I
don't know if they will cool I guess
time will tell mountain Peter thank you
so much going on talking to have a mess
about Mary maker and the wii u and let
us know what you think about whe you do
you play one yourself do you own one do
you own wanna not play games are you
playing my ohmic right now I let us know
in the comments below all right we got a
bunch more stuff coming up Metal Gear
Solid V never heard of it and the
phantom pain it's all anyone's talking
about in the office we're going to talk
about it in just a second but first of
all we were brand new show coming to
gamespot com from Dave Jewett and Lisa
James over the UK it's all about one of
my favorite video game franchises here's
a trailer for the fallout 4 show
the time
hey guys I'm Dave the brand-new host
here at gamespot com joined today by
Lucy and I'm going to be kicking things
off with a show all about fallout first
episode is going to be a brief history
and the fallout universe but the second
episode is only need your help so we're
going to be playing the first fallout
game obviously we need an intrepid
explorer to send out into the wasteland
so that's where we need your help give
us your ideas for character name stats
perks build gender everything in the box
below or tweet it at us I'm at least
James games I'm at a regular Dave we
will choose the best adventurer from all
the comments and tweet and the one that
we use in the Let's Plays will win a
special prize so make sure you stay
tuned to gamespot com fallout show is
coming out on Thursday and stay safe out
there wasteland
nuggets out of 5 the phantom pain is all
anyone in this goddamn office has been
talking about after the past weeks all
your fault Peter brand a 10g much more
Brown my fault is it kajima is full to
this could use it's a pretty great game
Mike my heart are you enjoying it yeah
I'm really liking it this whole weekend
that's all I did uh talking about it is
difficult because there weren't two
spoiler territory I need anybody in this
office to finish the game there's like
I'm at like things that come out of
people's mouths I'm like yeah but oh yes
here he's constantly grunting and
sighing from where like his desk someone
says something like so I'm like five
percent and after like 20 hours or
something yeah so don't worry we're not
gonna get into spoilers here on today's
job but we are gonna talk about
something like the interesting things
that have happened to us during random
missions the interesting moments that
make like a metal gear game not talking
about stuff that we unlock or things
that haven't but like just interesting
things that have happened i guess the
wonderful fruits of emergent gameplay
which happen in this game speaking of
emerging fruits i did find a cassette
tape with the sound of his soldier
pooping I find that too yeah I wish you
could set it as the sound on your
helicopter do you like that Segway yeah
that's pretty good at the pc version
I've seen people you can basically just
put in like any old mp3 into that folder
and just like make the helicopter oh
yeah cuz that was like the wrestling yes
that's right yeah dirty Dan Reicher did
that I'm sorry and you could do that
with the Phuket cuz that as well every
time the helicopter comes cuz I said it
like an hour or two into the game and
now every time the helicopter comes be
to pick me up or like support it's like
playing take on me by haha like every
well if it really takes the edge off I
can really tense situation was like did
it it no dude yeah you're coming in the
distance like a I guess or the creepy
creepy helicopter what type of moments
have you had that sort of stand out to
you better bring uh this was something I
found early on that I thought was like
maybe a glitch or something but then
we've determined that this is a real
mechanic in a game is sledding in the
cardboard box yeah so when you're in the
box you're crouched but you can stand up
and run into a sprint and if you hit
square if you're on PlayStation to dive
if you fall on a decline you will
actually slide down and so like you can
find some nails
really tall and go for like 30 seconds
like straight and it's it's really fun
like it stupid and simple but I don't
know it's fun you can use it to escape
uh-uh presumably have not done so okay
but I feel like a part of this game is
gonna be like hunting down the sickest
slopes yeah like really just [ __ ]
guest a tuna gamespot.com yeah it's
coming soon and Mike what's at the
moment you were talking today about a
mission that I played last night which
is pretty cool yeah there's a mission
later on where you just have to pretty
much I don't think it's a spoiled little
up vehicles you just have to blow up
vehicles and they're on like planned
routes that you have to or route if
you're one of those people thank you
yeah that you have to kind of just like
do a certain amount of them in a certain
amount of time and I had c4 planted on
the road in one spot like two of them
and then I had another one that I kind
of just forgot about because I pressed
the wrong button to set it okay and I
went prone waiting because I knew they
were gonna be along the path and all of
a sudden I saw just waiting and I threw
on rebel yell by billy idol because
that's one of my favorite songs the game
to play and then they came along and i
press triangle nothing happened but i
was getting i got points for something
oh wow during what i got it for cuz the
trucks in front of me were fine press
triangle few more times of blow him up
and I realized the 1i just like the
throw away when I had accidentally put
on the ground before head blown up like
some other vehicle Wow yeah I never went
back to check but it just kind of cool
that that came out of that situation
because it wasn't expecting that
obviously it wasn't planned I mean I'll
tell people to nature was planned but I
was running around on d horse with a
rocket launcher which I adjust and I
guess researched and I hadn't actually
used it before so like the same mission
where it's like you'd shut the blow it
blow up a bunch of vehicles and I like
okay well I do I find like the highest
point in the topography and like stay up
there and like crouch and like get in a
good place for this anti-tank weapon and
like just get it down the sights an
issue and I did that a couple of times
and I realized it's like so many of
these vehicles to blow up that I'm there
never all going to come to me on time
yeah so I hop on the horse and I'm like
looking for a place to like use the
rocket launcher and I'm like what if I
can use the rocket launcher while on
this horse which could never be the case
in the real world when Hideo Kojima
doesn't give a [ __ ] so I was like
running around on the horse d horse
would like this rocket
[ __ ] shoulder just like taking shots
and I was amazing and then one of them
turned around and saw me I like just
blew the crap at adi horse and I'm it
flew across the the the dirt in behind a
rock speaking of ready Rod blowing the
crap out of the horse I got the command
that you can just have him defecate it's
yeah I don't I haven't used it yet but
that's like the last thing I unlocked
before stopping to play last night to
fecal topics just one yeah yeah okay any
more thing yeah oh okay emerging
gameplay from marrakech if you play the
recording of the poop in the bath no
wait a min why can't sink why can't
there just be a command for him to
imitate pooping why do I have to get the
consent of nine out of ten ID for
something that wasn't willing to record
that feasible yeah ok that's pretty
great uh isn't it thing with the earlier
games they're all these little things
like that to find like you know like
that the stuff in the locker and Mel
yourself you're releasing the models
posters yeah was like now they've gone
out yourself I've so huge is kind of
like baffling to how many little things
i'm sure people start finding you did
somebody with a Supply Drop yes no I
just found out today you could do that
yeah kill myself what a supply he
doesn't really kill you just kind of now
but I've randy was telling you can do it
too quiet oh really hey no spoilers
let's keep at it on yeah yeah that's
what I heard today as well do it can do
2d Horace probably as well speaking of
the horse and supply drops were all good
segways all over the place um I the
first time I decided to try a sliding in
the box I had previously called in d
horse like a buddy supply drop whatever
it's called to the top of slope I just
beaten like a boss I was kind of
celebrating head you know take on me
playing and I went to slide down the
hill and all sudden d horse drops in
front of me and I hit it and he did that
Winnie and he went like flying under
side it was worried I had done more
damage but he got back up Oh once I
dropped into a level and was like riding
them the road on d horse and which but
it's never not going to be weird saying
d horse it's just a just [ __ ] leave
name Fort Worth and and there's a truck
coming towards me it was like really
early and I didn't I was like freaked
out I was like [ __ ] I jumped off the
earth and Ron I've totally forgot about
this and I ran behind like a boulder and
just like douve bind it as the
chocolates come around the corner yeah
and I hear going
[ __ ] Mayo d horse and I turned the
corner and the guys are like getting out
of the car the horse is on the ground
and yeah just [ __ ] perfect shot the
man it was a perfect opportunity to kill
it's actually a really good tactic to
use during one of those like missions we
have to blow up tanks and stuff oh
really you've used that oh yeah yeah cuz
you're good they're not gonna they're
gonna brighten up horse or they're gonna
get out and say whoa yeah get out of the
way any other moments come to mind you a
mission without using reflex before I'd
yeah IM vinaya i still didn't get the
aspen oh just i think i just took a
really long time but yeah I was it was
one of those ones read it was a the side
task was to extract a prisoner and I had
him on my back and I always get really
tense someone's on my back was you know
we have less options especially when you
can all use a sidearm you know just yeah
and I was walking through the village
with him on my back some one of these
people and there's like three guys are
there I mean I knew because they were
previously marked so I saw them kind of
searching they had something in alerted
them i think only open the door too
loudly and i just made it through
without alerting anyone extracted him
with a full and rode away on the horse
playing some sort of song got picked up
and went out without people knowing i
was there is like that could have easily
gone wrong so many ways but yeah just
got lucky and I I guess patience paid
off it's great when you get like that
like sand storm comes in at just the
best time you look like [ __ ] yeah when
you're like scouting out a mission like
how am I gonna do is oh I'm storm
approaching I had one where I had to go
in and collect this like this like
really battered prisoner like an extract
him and I had I found this other
prisoner first who I was like carrying
him out and then I went down into like
there was like a grill underneath the
base you could like crawl under 11 at a
good solid one saw but I dropped him in
and then there was like no way of
getting ready cuz you can't climb out
with the body yeah and you can't push
him down yeah kick his body damn it then
the grill uh so I was like I got a
[ __ ] fool to them but like no one
else knew I was in the base yeah so I
like just Fulton the guy I was I
realized oh my god I can fold to them
and then popped him up and then
literally it was just like look like
everyone just yeah zoned in on me so I
run in I'm like okay I better get the
other guy and I ran in got the real
prisoner carried a mouse and there was
like three guys like reflex mode like
coming up the stairs and I
have my like gone unlike ah throw this
prisoner I'm like he's probably gonna
die but he was all right did you find a
little Hedgehog that was crawling around
those little vents no oh yeah I've seen
a rat I've seen the Hedgehog as well
though and like you there you couldn't
fold in them obviously but when I saw
the Hedgehog later in the wild I was
like sweet but you can't do it you
actually you can capture them you get
these little animal traps naive so you
leave it out and then just randomly like
over time would be like oh no you got an
animal to support team brought it back
to base for you I just got I had it but
haven't used it so I've laid some traps
today yeah really want some hedgehogs
for what reason got to go fast okay blue
head shots good job no I don't know
sorry i was done but i don't was dumb no
because you have a zoo where are these
hedgehogs gonna go in the zoo good mean
muggin the camera that's just kind of
like mean buggin they're just gotta like
crawl underneath the barriers and then
just like oh yeah probably just like
lemmings yeah these moments keep
happening it's what I love about it it's
like you can't talk about the story
stuff cuz your spoiler but we keep
coming into the office and having these
like crazy like little asides about it
and you've obviously paid more of the
games than anyone does this continued do
you think do you keep like finding new
ways to enjoy the game like thread 100
hours plus of metal gear solid oh yeah
like uh like what one point you unlock
the water pistol and like it's just like
a little squirt gun and I hadn't really
thought about much about I thought it
was kind of a gimmick but I only
recently found out that you can use that
to like blind soldiers so if they catch
you they're like oh no and it cancels
the reflex and the alert and you can use
it to take out electronics as well oh
wow so it totally does all these layers
keep appearing that I never knew existed
before so yeah I mean there's and again
I'm only forty-six percent now after
maybe another eight hours like there's
still so much to tap into yeah yeah so
many weird stuff to find and discover
Mike my hardy Peter Brown thanks for
coming on talking about Metal Gear Solid
thank you Bob thank you boss Thank You
boss okay it's great not your mother
loved that video game and let us know
what you think about make yourself i've
had the phantom pain any
interesting emergent gameplay moments
that you had yourself in the comment box
below not too much is that like your
hedgehog things I was about you may be
too dad jokey maybe a skull Mars we're
getting old man's fast forward that in
post yeah exactly I like it's all five
ten out of ten there you go on gay so
calm I can't wait to go back and play
some more I gotta hang out with you guys
for the rest of the day I gotta talk to
Eric tell you about destiny next that's
what I have to suffer through and we've
also got a crazy competition at the end
of the show which we're gonna tell
people all about as well is it really
crazy it's crazy it's Gears of War
console that looks all crazy nope not
crazy enough for you how about gears of
war without a horse taking a poop on now
that's crazy that's what Hideo Kojima
would have given if that if you had the
chance and we're gonna be back in a
second it's my destiny to point oh oh I
could have a first of all here's a
trailer for taking cake I think we
fought to keep our beautiful creation
safe
and now this beast has come claim to be
king
mara solve vows to no one
I'll Guardian got a good look on folks
whatever it was it turned cabal against
Kabbalah they are taken Oryx has arrived
I will take
whatever you kill Oryx will replace
Destiny's been out for a year ekti yep
time for new destiny to point o like my
hearty yep you guys excited you don't
look it I am mad st fans you can play an
all year you'd be trying to sell me on
destiny all year taking Kings just
around the corner tell me what this new
patch this is for everyone right yep
tell me what it what it gives two
players whether or not they're getting
the taken king or not why you want to go
you want to take it all right I'll start
and then you can fill in yeah you've
been playing this morning I played some
the the Padgett's actually pretty big
it's like almost 18 gigs right you ready
for that if you have crappy internet
good luck or even for us with fast
internet it was pretty slow but um if
you've got a bandwidth cap good look
guess so but um a lot of quality of life
I've kind of hearkened this a bunch but
it makes a big difference just like you
I itself is like way better you got like
better questing there's new quests
there's better way of tracking your
quest that you didn't have before that's
like MMO style you can like like kind of
stamping on the on your like main screen
like okay what do I need to keep doing I
need to kill seven more dudes instead of
going back my options you have 16 bounty
slots now up from 10 so more stuff to do
on top of that let's see what else is
there there's like there's new kiosks
your kiosks kind of house a lot of your
stuff like your shaders um your ship so
you don't kind of have to carry all that
stuff with you anymore you can just like
pick the ones you want and of course
there's new shaders and ships coming and
taking king as well so new infantry
system as well in the spa boy um there's
more vault space they've doubled it
which is a pretty big deal in terms of
inventory like like specifically with
gear or what do you mean like I guess
there well now you can do class items
which used to be just aesthetic and or
if you won't get trying to get
reputation for certain factions and a
pvp stuff it would go toward you know
that orbit feature monarchy but now
those actually give you defense as well
as certain stat like intellect
discipline strength and your ghost shell
also so um now that it's nolan north you
can call it i don't know yeah shell or
something so peter dinklage at northern
North in and you've been listening to it
this morning both of you Mike what do
you think about his performance I like
it a lot more I think Peter Dinklage
kind of a novelty just because it was
Peter Dinklage in a video game and it
was I got so used to hearing him like
say all these lines when you're doing
the story missions that I kind of forgot
you know how good it could be to
actually have a voice actor who's
obviously he's long north as a veteran
no he sound a lot more like c-3po it's
kind of that you know computerized
digital crazy modulation on the voice or
Chris waters had made the comparison to
343 Guilty Spark from the ice yeah and
it that's definitely the best comparison
it sounds a lot like that high-pitched
you know like kind of emphatic I'm
really happy to be here and tell you
everything but I like it a lot it's a
nice change it's uh it's not as monotone
as Dinklage was it's interesting
actually considering the sort of news
over the weekend about the the lawsuit
and how much the story changed
apparently the story was kind of
completely overhauled I wonder if in a
couple years will find out that Dinklage
had like lots of lines scrapped or like
it was a totally different type of
character or something to that end
because clearly like this voice
performance has been done with the
script that we have right now in mind
and in terms of the these will talk
about the questions I come in terms of
the sort of overall changes to you I in
quality of life stuff is this stuff to
think Eric that like destiny fans we're
looking for is this very much like the
list of things that you would have
wanted or are these kind of piecemeal
changes that you're you're happy for but
you didn't really know you want it I
think uh like there are probably some
changes that I'm like oh yeah that's
really cool that I have that like I
don't know if I aspired to have a lot of
these changes but like it's we've had
this conversation in the office me and
Mike about how kind of some of these UI
changes and some of these quality of
life changes are kind of what Reaper of
souls did for diablo 3 right a really
big deal and like you kind of don't
really think about them until you
actually have them and you're just like
oh wow this is like tremendously better
or this is I why didn't we have this
before and you just it just simplifies
things it makes things cleaner better
and then because of that you like it
like the fact that you can turn in
bounties without having to go into the
tower that's a pretty big deal you know
like something like that and another big
kind of change that's going to help
people that maybe haven't played it as
much or even people that have played it
is you can use your ghost now just scan
like stuff in the world and then Dan was
also telling me that when you go into a
patrol mission nolan bot or whatever we
want to call it will actually kind of
tell you
story instead of like dinklage how like
before he's like let's see what we can
do here like instead he'll kind of give
you like a small no other verse isn't
this a bit more yeah then otter than
there as well did we mention we have
mentioned the light system no let's all
be changed up as well right yeah so
people that have played a lot of Destiny
liked a you know like to get to 34 or
anything above you know 20 it's all
reliant on light which each armor piece
inherently has a certain above a certain
level has a number of light soldier up
until that point it's like a general you
grind XP by competing missions but then
after a level 20 it turns into this yeah
this other form of currency basically so
now light is not actually based off of
like certain items you get it's just
it's an average of all your your total
defense and offense so it's not this
stat that's kind of tying in to your
level as much it's more of just an
indicator of how good your gear is but
you know like later on like we're
playing the patch today and a lot of the
higher-level story heroic missions like
hard difficulty we're all you know
recommended this amount of light so now
it's kind of telling you like your
character is probably not good enough
yet all right let's but that's all tied
to just playing more and finding other
things and you know finding quest that
are going to give you like legendary
rewards so from what I've played I
played you know a lot of 2 point 0 at
this point just prior to today and it
was it definitely seems like your time
is being respected more you know like I
think hey and I kind of differ you know
what's your what's your deck he loves
grinding so right you might disagree
with me loves the grind yeah like I mean
he decides I point to what he just
actually said that actually I didn't
think about till right now like the fact
that we can't do heroic story now
because of like a finite number of like
I think you have to be like 240 light
study does that mean that like anyone
that doesn't by taking king can't
actually get there cuz we can't get
there right now because it's just not
enough yeah well I'd only way like
normal mission well no I think when
taken King releases in a week that year
to stuff will be enough to get you to
lie regardless of whether you have taken
care or not the patch itself you can get
like better stuff next week right but I
don't know i'm not sure if you can
actually get that stuff from legendaries
so if that's the case that's kind of
shitty i hope that's not well we'll
investigate further yeah but um
I like in terms of the grind like that i
enjoy i think i look forward to the raid
and i think this time around having the
raid back after not having in a house of
wolves is a pretty big deal and I think
it'll also help differentiate some of
the hardcore players from maybe some
other more casual players but the casual
players this time around have so much
more to do there's so many more quests
and stuff to farm and grind and they're
trying to reward you mooring and make
your experience kind of more rewarding
like I said to respect your time as Mike
was saying which i think is fine I just
hope that it doesn't become like super
easy like to casual I don't want it to
go like like wow cataclysm we're looking
for raid alright like press a button
yeah and like my buddies AFK eating
dinner I'm like what are you doing man
he's like oh meeting dinner it's alright
like you you guys got this yeah yeah I
got this right click Add on it just does
the game for me yeah so I don't I don't
think it's gonna be like that it's just
I don't want it to gravitate too far
over I know what they're doing they're
trying to find a way to find a happy
medium of a pc lemarchal regional
hardcore and also kind of getting
bringing new people in casting a wider
net do you think that like if you were
to like guests at a percentage of the
amount of Destiny players we're going to
by taking king what would you say
current like currently yeah they're
playing oh I would say like 80 80 plus
percent night person like 65-70 yeah it
feels it feels like that edge dodos it
feels like at least too late if you're
saying like regular players yeah I'd
agree it's probably like 80 it seems
pretty pretty like monumental as far as
how much is gonna change games
especially after next week because you
know there's no anybody who like even if
you just spend your entire time with the
game playing patrol missions you'll hit
40 if you play enough and I mean it'll
take you a lot longer than like the way
Tay plays or I play but it it's just
it's it's accessible for people that
want to just be casual with it and it's
also you know there's still exotic
bounty chains and whatnot that you can
if you want to go through the grind of
that you can get those like you know
specific weapons everything so from what
I've seen from my understanding it seems
like it's doing good job of like in
developing both kinds of players yeah I
think they're going to get more people
to because like imagine if you didn't
buy the expansions when you play destiny
right yeah you're paying 60 bucks yeah
but you're paying sixty dollars i think
i'm pretty sure you're paying sixty
dollars for both expansions
taken king so you get all of that for 60
bucks instead of like what a wondrous
yeah yeah for us so does that sour you
at all no but we've had this
conversation before Lee I feel like it's
like the time I spent playing the game
for how like costs associated great
great for me perfect for me good it was
like not not a good investment for
everyone like someone that buys destiny
plays it for like four or five hours
like maybe yourself doesn't like where
it's going you stop bad sixty dollar
investment I pay twenty dollars for an
expansion I get two to four weeks if not
more worth of content that's plenty of
investment not bad all right I taken
king will have a review up on gamespot
soon we will have a review progress up
on Tuesday we're going to play the raid
which comes out in the 18th okay so next
tuesday next week we'll have sort of you
in progress hey myself and for other
people from the office will be going at
that okay cool so we'll have to get you
back on next week don't tell us all
about how that one's playing well
probably live stream into so oh yeah so
we also we have running bet running bet
what's the running back oh man steak
dinner oh [ __ ] fatal day okay just the
two of you yep who can beat 41st who can
reach 40 and why don't a fatal flaw in
his plan today okay it shouldn't affect
it that much okay well we'll tell us in
the internet will let you know if it's
all right yeah yeah uh prefer it medium
rare just haha what is it what's the
flaw what's the flaw he just has one
more bounty than I do so that's like a
little bit more experience I thought it
was gonna be worse than that because
like so the since the patch came out
today I was planning ahead of time but I
didn't plan ahead for this patch and how
the patch actually changed some of the
mechanics of rice so then I kind of
screwed myself but then it turns out he
wasn't that far ahead so I'm not that
word and he's played it already
technically hmm a little bit so I that's
why no problem medium rare over you both
like medium rare my choice by tues
medium rare is all right you have them
ready for that red we're on the cusp of
40 yeah they're very agrees yeah all
right maybe we'll have medium rare steak
on the lobby and next week thanks so
much for joining us folks gentlemen and
you guys watching at home let us know
what you take a destiny to point over
the patch have you downloaded it is it
still downloading are you not watching
this right now so you get an extra
bandwidth and play some more God and
destiny and they're gonna pick up to
take King let us know in the comments
below all right gents that was a fun
episode lobby
lots of video games coming ash how would
you guys feel about winning a brand new
gears of war branded console does it
have a chainsaw it does not have a
chainsaw stature I don't believe it as a
chainsaw touch but if you want to win Oh
wonderful live viewers or those watching
the VOD you can go to the URL on screen
right now Tanya calm /g s gears xbox and
xbox one sick Gears of War graphics on
it done by mr. Chris Matthews from the
coalition himself well lose the art
director I think on gears for and yeah
so I check it out hit thought you were
on your comm /g s gears Xbox that God
says I go over their feelings of little
details and you get put in the
sweepstakes to win that bad boy console
that you this only is that US only it's
probably a sony i'm gonna say to us only
murders I'm gonna be honest you don't
want to if you live in europe you don't
wanna and NTS i'll actually know their
region for your anything I think we Jim
free one of them's not and it [ __ ] me
over as I came over here I have an
excess or that your PA oh hell one or
whatever dude my ps3 like totally did
not make it over here when i flew when i
moved here like two years ago my xbox
360 is like there's no front plate it
like i have to open the CD with a
[ __ ] knife and it's the only like
pile 360 like left in san francisco it's
probably said i could buy of like four
hundred dollars but so raggedy so
whenever i play like 43 on a stream at
home all the time and it's like every
time I turn off please don't [ __ ]
explode please don't [ __ ] say a tool
kit yeah yeah I need to pay for like
three on pc so i need to do solves a
problem what I can do gentlemen you
gonna do for us to make it a what are
you up to huh destiny stuff hopefully
today we'll have like a king cole vs
Nolan you can decide who you like better
cool um and then if mgs everyone loves
them's yes so maybe help out over there
play some of that boom up poop yeah poop
on stuff I addy horse poop on me and
then I flies on me but I can't yeah you
can just lie down behind him ago do it
turns out you don't know where the
shower is that right I don't know what
showers oh I'm not check the poop made
me helpful made the Flies be all over me
or if that just happens anyway but as
apparently there's a there's a it's
really annoying cuz if I you like go in
first person mode like you'd be gone
this [ __ ] flies
I'm fine front of me that's awesome I
hate it i might go eating for the rest
of the week uh just destiny preparing
for my steak and later on just
civilization beyond Earth getting ready
for that expansion as well cool November
but we'll have some stuff on that later
yeah we're gonna have a bigger thing
hopefully I can figure out that fly
mechanic you're talking about yeah
doesn't sound too difficult you just
don't let the horse it's bunny our guys
don't shower it's awful don't do it
thanks so much for watching if you're
watching on gamespot on a gaming youtube
com for tots gamespot or twigs on TV
forward sighs gamespot thank you so much
for hanging it for watching this on
demand on gamespot would have all this
stuff of course broken head on youtube
engage body phone a check it out there
thank you so much to everyone in the
production crew josh ow marrakech dan
moharrak eric day you're here great
shirt you always know what Eric's gonna
be on the show because you wear is a
nice shirt look at this shirt or tie
thinks I'm gonna have to interview or
he's gotten any of you with what a
competitor who could it be find out next
week on the lobby mmm
you